è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e questo
modo io sono fa vj oggi andiamo artico
scrivo all'auto limiterà gara ma rimasti
che ci rimangono perché siamo sul
vulcano di modo dove c'è frodo perché
c'è ganja perché è pronto decolla ora
che siamo partiti da cinque secondi non
ci capisco è già più scalzo vabbè mi
butto giorni sono ancora vivo bene mi
posso salvare ragazzi dobbiamo allora ci
mancano 10 fottute st wright per finire
sto maledetto gioco quindi muoviamo le
chiappe allora come si fa a fare andato
ok perfetto
dobbiamo andare qui in questa zona a
punto sino a 2133 zone va bene rai
allora facciamo così facciamo 5 st
wright se riesco in questo episodio e
poi nel prossimo faccio le ultime cinque
perché se no è impossibile la mia buca e
cercando di saltare sulla luna e ora è
bloccata alla summa perché una multa gel
che risalta senti ragazzi andiamoci
cos'è quello perché c'ha le ali
mou canu calata se montiamo ai propri
cei a cavallo delle mucche alate giusto
io adesso me la tengo na bastardo ferma
la bocca e mi ha voluto strong pro sesto
e così ragazze ma staccati brutto
stronzo è mia la mucca buongiorno
signora che cosa ci fa sulla luna offeso
il satellite ma non l equipaggiamento da
spia ma non l'equipaggiamento da spia
non può aiutarmi sei una spia cioè che
cazzo cosa vuol dire devo darti una cosa
vuoi occhiali da sole
questo è è perfetto
ragazzo gli aveva già gli occhiali se
nessun altro paio addosso di barbera che
io io sto gioco più vado avanti più non
capisco chi vuoi staccare dal mio
[ __ ] culo bene ragazzi rai di andare
a prendere la strada it ma prima voglio
capire chi è questo
gli occhiali sono figli sono i miei
grazie lo studente ha catturato il
maestro cosa sono pronto a trattare per
la sua liberazione
senti qua la banana è la risposta a
tutto prendi questa è l'inverso il mio
amico scimmia super intelligente va bene
ragazzi ci si affacciamo asta st wright
perché sta uscendo di testa infiltrati
nella stazione spaziale per spegnere il
supercomputer dove vissero in fibra che
poi così favi bond ce la posso fare
ragazzi ci posso fare il veterinario
malvagio non trova animali nello spazio
mostra di un animale che può vivere
senza gravità un animale che può vivere
ma cosa squalo attuale uno squalo nello
spazio si è a posto
vabbè il nero è senz'altro disostruire
di istruire questo cervello
aiutalo a riempirlo di sapere quante
realizzerei dexter però non posso farlo
miss allora prendiamoci un libro un
libro nel cervello vai così
perché cos'è sta roba ragazzi ci siamo
ma non solo
l'ultima stanza sembra vuota trovo modo
per sbloccare per bloccare la stazione
spaziale tira la leva tirana leva c'è
quella telecamera che mi sta parlando
ora facciamo solid snake dopo devo
passare quando non mi guarda o cosa non
lo so ma io la tiro lo stesso tutte le
porte ma non sapevo lo sapevo che mi
trappola vano la star di cosa va
catturato stesso per computer viene
messo fuori uso la stazione spaziale
perderà l'energia e la gabbia si aprirà
devo devo cosa devo fare allora
diluvio diluvio nello spazio vai cos'è
ce la dovremmo fare ragazzi che abbiamo
fatta
aprite sono libero praga questa è la
missione di infiltrazione più strana che
io abbia mai basso ma ce l'abbiamo fatta
51 st wright ma bonaga cambiamo zona che
qua abbiamo praticamente quasi fatto
curdo
non so non so bene che cosa cos'è
crateri di cana va bene proviamo a stare
qui questo è proprio tutto nello spazio
c'è un casino
raga e c'è un marziano che ancora la
nuca di prima e ovunque stavo che va bè
prendiamo cos'è questo è quello che è
andato su marte oseresti superare un
cratere saltando con un rover lunare ma
guarda per mac bastardo se non meteorite
voleva prendere in mano già fatto
saltatore lunare respingi l'invasor in
arrivo sa ma invasori marziali dallo
spazio raga questo dovrebbe essere una
figata
ci prova va bene ci siamo è pieno di
alieni i marziani st l'ipotesi la
colonia anulare crei qualcosa che mette
in fuga i gatti di gatti alieni i gatti
alieni ci devo mettere kakanj alien cani
alieni cannes alieno cane cane alieni
ragazzi il cane secco vai cos'è cane
alieno grandissimi questi sono sistemi
di difesa all'avanguardia
ok ragazzi cosa è quello i marziani
hanno trasformato un germoglio in una
pianta carnivora fai quel che è
necessario per proteggere rifugio da
questa pianta o mio dio che era nata mai
così granata si granata su scritto vai
vai ciò potremo fare
l'ice granata e ancora è ancora vivo
cazzo ragazzi e più sveglia di quanto
pensassi meteorite meteorite mai così un
commento dita prende in testa c'è
passione perché s'è creata l'insalata
quando fatto fuori una pianta col
meteorite non fare fuori non distruggere
lo specchio che gli anni di sfiga sono
tuoi poi son cazzi tuoi
non me ne frega niente sono gli struzzi
soccorsi tua ok bravo infatti tavolo
detto che porta la sfiga grande ce
l'abbiamo fatta
va bè ragazzi mi accontento interagisce
ce la possiamo fare la gara invasori
marziani siamo a 3 st wright ne mancano
due ce la possiamo fare la vera mente
cos'è questo pericolo buco nero crea
oggetti che questa era questo bellissimo
questo e perché
perché c'è un [ __ ] eschimese sulla
luna perché chi è questa ragazzi cosa
devo decostruire il buco nero va bene
cosa o quel buco nero potrebbe
distruggere il pianeta
metti con il cannone qualcosa che posso
ostruirlo qualcosa qualcuno c'è una
persona lo mette la palla è jack sparso
è lui salvo la situazione jack vai anche
al nostro di sparare spara vai vai jack
cos'è il cotè grande jack jack è ha
salvato la situazione
no cosa fai giacché non devi di
marchiare devi salvare la situazione vai
nel buco nero jack no niente jack di
morchia e va bene l'unico cos'è questo
mettere calore qualcuno che studia lo
spazio
chi è che studia lo spazio scusate
alieno un alieno è l'alieno penso
l'abbia già studiato tempo farà mai così
l'alieno ci vive nello spazio non è che
lo studia ma va bene uguale non importa
che mira la presa del pieno vabbè non
importa se uno con uno sturalavandini
sembra che ricercatore non ritornerà non
me ne frega niente prova costruire buco
nero con qualcosa di peloso che cazzo e
big boot di put cioè lui ma perché ma
perché ragazzi perché nessuna delle
soluzioni ha funzionato carica il
cannone con qualcosa che possa che
facessimo delle buco nero ragazzi posso
farcela
che so bomba atomica mano atomica che ho
scritto non lo so bomba a dolciume
dolciume atomico paese ma l'ha preso ma
cosa un buon bologna alla crema contro i
buchi neri giusto e chi è questa non lo
so non ha funzionato e ricercata la
soluzione fa implodere il buco nero
inviando un oggetto di massa immensa di
marmi massa immensa che ne so
il sole e sotto il sole contro il buco
nero poi così questa è una cosa un po
strana trova bene è grande ce l'abbiamo
fatta è una cosa non so come un sole
abbia fatto entrare nei cannoni ma va
bene così il pericolo è scampato ma
anche una storia già possiamo fare la
caccia possiamo fare assolutamente dov'è
dov'è quella roba dove doveva trovo
l'ultima st wright corsa e qui ok
ragazzi amo nell'ultima zona che è lui o
che non ho visto faccio l'ultima st
wright poi aiuta lastronata prigioniero
a scappare la prigione aliena è una
prigione aliena questa grande questa mi
sa che è un riferimento tipo ad halo
pistola ad acqua ragazze ci prova a
tirarti fuori non so se funziona sta
indietro e pericolosissimo ok
evidentemente non funziona credo che io
debba [ __ ] pensavo che si così si
potessero attaccare che genio che il
genio assurdo non ci credo non lo so chi
gioca non lo sapevo dobbiamo dobbiamo
superare i dettagli cancelli laser degli
alieni ragazzi ho fatto una cosa epica
non lo sapevo
va bene allora speriamo sta roba
attaccatutto che la pistola la cosa
regalo specchio lo specchio mi serve per
forza sicuro non so che mazzarri grande
tipo non mi ricordo che gioco era col
rosso è grave non importa cos'è quella
roba dobbiamo illudere il cane senza
quello è un cane quello è un cane rega
provoco il postino il cane per il segue
il postino non lo so
se funziona ma veramente ha forse dio
mio
vabbè allora un postino dovevo farlo
alieno il postino mi sa perché c'è del
cibo per cani non lo so va bè ragazzi
muoviti andiamo alla nave rai che già
stiamo facendo stiamo evadendo ma perché
io tanto c'è una maschera bruttissima
beh dobbiamo riparare ragazzi è andata
la navicella ripa rami come la mia
strada e glassa come potrà andarmela p
faccio io faccio io chiave inglese a non
facciamo così mecca meccanico fa tutto
lui è così non ci prendiamo una birra o
no cazzo mi ha lasciato il free
essenziali tare non te ne andrai senza
diverse ho preso la strada è meccanico
tienilo tu perché se non scappa è
tienilo al guinzaglio barrera gatti
abbiamo 55 st wright
io le chiuderei qui per questo episodio
perché è successo di tutto il prossimo
dovrebbe essere l'ultimo anzi che
sicuramente sarà l'ultimo vabbè ragazzi
io per questo episodio la chiudo qui è
visto è piaciuto come al solito lasciate
un commento vi piace anche alla pagina
di facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non si erano
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo in
un prossimo video bella ragazzi